when do I start looking like an
effortless girl on vacation rather than
like oh that girl fell asleep in a train
station with her hair in a ponytail hi
guys I'm on vacation right now making a
video for you because I just I want to I
have the option not to I haven't made a
Friday been doing the last three weeks
if you haven't noticed okay okay oh
there she is
easy breezy beautiful struggle girl hi
my name is grace Helbig if you did not
know now you know your life is different
now I'm in Hawaii and yes I did set this
is in the background because I bring my
luggage into a room like someone
bringing their food poisoning into a
toilet everywhere yeah let me show you I
made a huge effort not to show you so
let me show you that makes them here's
some slob
there's some slob everywhere we swap
swap today we are doing a Q&A oh wait
and then I'm gonna make sure those
flowers you those flowers make me look
like when the front row so today we are
doing a Q&A because that's all my brain
can braid right now I went on Twitter
and asked you guys for questions using
the hashtag asked brace and now I'm
going to answer them that's just the
smoke alarm I thought that was part of
my hair have you registered to vote yes
I have I definitely have I've been
telling other people to vote and I
thought the other day wait a minute have
I registered and so I went online and
the high register to vote and they
should be getting my ballot in the mail
take me seriously but if you are like me
and you're unsure of your status in
terms of registering to vote go to Iowa
vote calm and you can very easily either
sign up to vote check your status make
sure you're registered still so mmm and
so important so please please please
please please make sure that you live in
the United States you're registered to
vote how many times have you watched 30
30 to be honest um I would say probably
somewhere between 6 to 9 times 69 69 I'm
watching all the way through a handful
of times and then I've watched bits and
pieces of it that would add up to full
viewings so yeah between six and nine
times 69th I did you know that the water
that splashes from the toilet on your
bone after a food
calls decided kisses no I did not know
thank you for that information
life is about educating yourself on the
daily basis beside his kisses Wow a real
Greek tragedy if you ask me yep you
create a reality show what would it be
and who would host ah I don't know that
I want to create my own reality show I
will say though that I started watching
finding prince charming which is hosted
by Lance Bass who is a guest on my
podcast that you can now watch the video
version on full screen and listen to the
audio version on soundcloud iTunes this
has nothing to do with that plug being
part of this but Lance came on the
podcast and started talking about this
reality show that he's been hosting
that's out on logo TV called finding
Prince Charming it's basically the
bachelor bachelorette but for a gay man
and a bunch of gay male contestants and
it is fascinating and I'm obsessed and
if any of you are watching please let me
know it's so good
what actually it's Thursday night when
I'm shooting this video oh my god
there's no episode on tonight oh my god
I'm in paradise but all I want to do is
sit in my room and watch finding prince
charming how do you feel about scary
clown epidemic sweeping the nation
you mean contouring I've had that joke
locked and loaded for a good 45 minutes
there that's good do you have any tips
for studying and not procrastinating in
an online college class yes stop
participating in the ask grace hashtag
what's the worst haircut you've ever had
oh no everything's failing perfect okay
we got to fix them once when I was nine
I was mauled by a cow and I think it
scarred me for life have you had any
interesting Carroll experiences
I have not thought this is illegal it
has to be illegal is this this is a
crime at what point does it become a
crime this seems like a crime how are
the leaves fastened to the head this is
a crime this is illegal and also this is
a crime are there any plans for Noel to
show or this might get weird JA in the
future I missed the live comedy shows
maybe when will you pull out the pulling
B 1 2 3 again the important question any
time she wants have you guys seen the
trailer for haters back off the Miranda
sings new Netflix show it is so good and
if you haven't seen it
do yourself a favor favorite fall
memories one time I tripped over a dog
at a party Dobson reading buffering do
you think hannah has any secrets that
might surprise you probably yes I'm so
excited to read buffering Hannah Hart's
new book if you haven't pre-ordered
Chyna's book already please do buffering
book calm I believe he's the website
she's it's good it's gonna be good
I've only read one chapter of it which
is a chapter about me that she had me
read so I could give permission that she
could write that about me and so I don't
know what the rest of the book has in
store but if it's anything like the
chapter I read it's gonna be a really
good book balancing question mark yes
exclamation point have not seen the show
but I have been listening to the
soundtrack more and more and it is just
so when talented people do cool
innovative new things in the world of
entertainment it makes me so excited
yeah any tips on getting out of school
go to school do all your work or
graduate and then you're out of school
for the rest of your life until you want
to go back oh that's it those are all
the A's I have for your Q's today guys
thank you so much for joining me in this
video if you liked it let me know in the
comments or by giving a thumbs up and
subscribe to this youtube channel
because we it's it's you never know
what's gonna happen
you never know it's unpredictable
exciting
I don't know what is the 27th pick in
your camera roll I didn't realize I
wasn't recording me sending this
question out loud so I'm doing a
voiceover okay 27 from the start or 27th
back I don't know I'm gonna go 27th back
one two three four five six 27 Oh week
when went that Diane Kang took of mabry
and I at the Streamy Awards recently and
I love this photo because you get to see
the hair that when DJ Diaz did for me so
beautifully and the back of the dress
that was super super cool and I don't
know how to showcase that on a red
carpet so thankfully Dan trip is oh but
you also get to see just a candid mamrie
face mamrie's not posing for a photo
this is just a normal May briefing like
sex and confidence everywhere she goes
even in the back hallways of a hotel at
an award show thank you for that
important question